Yes, ma'am.
I'll start again.
The internet is gone.
Yes, no problem.
I'll start from the beginning.
First of all, you all will have a login from school.audipay.in.
It will also be shared with you all.
To log in to it, you all have phone numbers.
You have to log in via OTP.
Then if you want, you can also set your password.
After logging in from here, send OTP to change password.
Everyone has an option.
You can also greet your passwords.
As soon as your ERP login is done, your OTP will be logged in.
Here you have the settings icon.
From where we have to set up.
In settings, you all have the option of academics.
By clicking on academics, you will have various options defined in which you have to work.
Is this much clear at the end of all of you?
Yes, it is clear.
Now what we have to do is create a timetable.
The first step for the timetable is to define the subjects in the system.
After defining the subjects, you have to define the subject in the subject class mapping.
So first of all, we have to define the subjects in the system.
You have the first option.
Right now I don't have any subject in the system.
You have the option to add a subject at the top.
You will click on this.
I am creating a subject.
English.
The name of the subject.
Then there is a unique code for the subject.
It is possible that the name of the subject is common, but it has a code that defines it.
I have added a code.
3-digit code ENG.
Then there is an assessment model.
Scholastic subject, co-scholastic subject.
Scholastic subjects are basically those subjects in which we have to do marks entry.
For example, like your GK.
In your primary classes, GK, which are your small classes, in that case your course is in scholastic or discipline.
Basically, you use grading criteria for that.
Teachers enter the grade.
So those subjects are the criteria for scholastic or discipline or skills.
We have made 4 assessment models.
Ma'am, can I interrupt a little?
Yes, tell me.
Ma'am, the name of the subject in English will be of everyone.
It is also in 7th.
Will this subject code be different for 6th and 7th?
No, no, no.
This subject code defines your subject.
It will not define your class.
It is only defining your subject.
It can be general knowledge.
You have to use general knowledge completely.
You have to use GK.
I have made the assessment model scholastic.
Sir, we have the option to define class and stream.
There are some subjects.
We want that when we create mapping,
it should only show in these particular classes.
It should not show in all of them.
This can be a subject.
In that case, you can map a particular class.
For example, there is a subject that I want.
When I create mapping for 5th and 6th class,
it should only display in that class.
It should not display in other classes.
It should not be able to add.
In that case, I can select this in a particular class.
For example, my English is for everyone.
I did not select a particular class.
I will add a simple one.
This is my subject.
In this way, you can add subjects according to your classes.
Or you can add a simple subject in the system.
You can add the data of the subjects.
Excuse me, ma'am.
Yes, ma'am.
Ma'am, can we skip the code?
Is it necessary to give?
Ma'am, it is necessary to give.
You can add something else according to your classes.
For example, I used ENG for English.
In this way, code is considered a mandatory field.
In our system, code is mandatory.
You can add anything according to your classes.
You can use HIN for Hindi.
You can use MAT for Math, kind of.
Okay.
This was the subject.
Sir, is there any query for any subject?
No, ma'am. It is okay.
Okay, sir.
I want to clarify one more thing.
The subjects that we have created,
it is possible that later you have to change
something in the name of the subject.
You feel that you have to change its name.
In that case, if you have only created
I have not added it in any class in mapping.
So, I can edit it until then,
whatever I want to edit in it.
But if I have added it in mapping,
then I cannot edit it from here.
Then I can only change its display name
from mapping.
I cannot change the name of the subject.
Okay, sir.
We have created the subjects.
Now, we have to map our created subjects
in their respective class.
Right.
That is an option in subject class mapping.
Okay.
You can call it subject course mapping
and subject class mapping.
In this, you have the first option,
add new subject class mapping.
Right. You will click on this.
Then you will define the class.
You are making it for the fifth class.
There is an option, we can multi-select it.
You feel that in fifth, sixth, seventh,
I have common subjects.
So, you can create three classes
together.
Class fifth, by default,
it will select the stream and by default,
it will select all the sections.
I will create a single section now.
Then, after that,
you have to add the detail of the subject.
It means, in class fifth,
you are getting the subjects.
You are defining the subjects.
Okay. I added the subject.
I have the list of the subjects
that I have created there.
I will type and select according to the drop down.
Now, the assessment model
that I added there,
I have got the assessment model.
Then, you have the subject type.
What is the subject type basically?
There are some subjects for some classes
which are optional subjects,
which are general,
which are not common for all the students.
Now, English is common for all the students.
So, all the students in this class,
I have to apply this subject
from here.
There is no option that
two kids have it and three kids don't have it.
So, we will do general.
But in case, we have
in class fifth, sixth, GK, drawing,
Punjabi, so all these subjects
are optional.
So, in that case,
you can use optional.
From here, you will do optional.
From here, you will define in subject mapping
that it is an optional subject.
All the students will not get it.
Then, you will define it in the next step.
Okay. For now,
I will do this as a general
and add it from here.
This is my mapping created
in which I have added one subject.
From here, you had the option
to add more subjects.
Other than this, all the subjects
will be added from here.
Next subject.
Your list will be created
in this class.
Okay, sir.
There is one more query in this part.
I will explain it.
Okay.
Now, we have
created the class and defined
the subjects. Now, basically,
who is the class teacher in this class?
Who is its coordinator?
There is no corresponding subject teacher.
So, we have to define that.
There is class 5th.
In class 5th, who is my class teacher?
You have the list of employees.
The ID of the employees that we have created.
You will define from here.
For example, this is my class teacher.
So, I have set it as a class teacher.
You can assign a coordinator
to any other employee.
In class teacher,
we have the option to map
a single employee.
Because class teacher is single
for a class.
But if you want to do multiple,
you can use the coordinator.
From here, you can map
all the coordinators for this class.
And one more thing.
Those who are mapped by class teacher
and coordinator, they have
all the subjects of a particular class.
So, they have access to all the subjects.
Now, you feel that you have to give
a single subject to a teacher.
For example, if he is a subject teacher,
from here, the subject teacher is mapped.
In the same subject teacher, you have the option
to set multiple subject teachers.
This was our teacher mapping.
Now, there is one more thing.
As I told you, by chance, you feel
that the name of the subject
I have to define something else.
So, in that case, this is the display name.
The display name that you will give,
in the future, like you will do marks entry
at the end of the student, which is visible
to the teacher, that display name
will appear, which you will give the display name.
Now, if I edit this normal from here,
for example, I have made this
single subject.
Now, I will edit this.
So, I have this teacher map in it.
It is showing you
what is the subject of English
and what is the employee edit.
I have created this.
I have not assigned this to anyone
because the display name I have put
ENG, now I have it everywhere
I am using the name of ENG.
There is an icon,
we have this edit.
After every mapping is created,
you can make any further changes in it.
Then, we have the option
to assign by default.
All the subjects added,
general subjects added,
you will select from here.
If you assign from here,
all the students will get it in the class.
I am not doing it now because
we are making it according to the test.
Even then, I am not assigning the students.
Okay, sir.
Let's move on to some doubts.
Will you tell me one thing?
Do you have the criteria for optional subjects?
Yes, we have.
Okay, sir. I will explain that once.
For example, the subject I have is
an optional subject.
It can be additional or vocational.
You can set it according to that.
Then, you can simply edit it.
Okay.
After that, you have defined
this optional test.
But from here, you can set it in bulk
for all the students.
Now, it is an optional subject,
so it won't be applied to all the students.
Now, how can we set it?
For that, you have a separate option
for assigned subjects.
We assign optional subjects from here.
You have selected the class.
You have a list of the students
from here.
Now, which of these students
do you want to assign the English optional subject to?
You will select the students
from here.
After selecting,
you have the option
to assign the subject.
You have created the option
and here you will get the subject.
As soon as you add the subject,
it will only apply to the students
whom you have selected.
It won't apply to all the students.
They have told us about the whole class.
The whole class will be assigned from there.
The subject class mapping
You have made it as a general map.
You have to make a general map
After making a general map,
you can directly edit and assign from here.
Click and assign from here.
I am not doing it now.
It will apply to all the students.
You have the option from outside
You have the same option from here.
Click and assign from here.
It will apply to all the students.
This was the part
of creating the subject class mapping.
According to this,
we will define the timetable.
For that, you will have the option
of creating the timetable.
You will do that part.
From here, we will define the timetable
of the subject and the teacher
how to map in the future.
For example,
I will create a timetable.
Add new timetable.
You have selected the class.
I have a single class in mapping.
You are making a timetable of single class.
After that, add new schedule.
Now, you will define
the lecture number.
Lecture number 1.
When is your lecture number 1 starting?
Start time, end time, or just a minute.
At least,
you have to do it 10 times.
Yes, sir.
Shall we continue?
Just a minute.
What we have to do is
add the schedule.
In the schedule, first we have
lecture number 1.
In the fifth class,
when is my lecture number 1 starting?
For example, my lecture starts
exactly at 8 am.
From 8 to
8.45,
my first lecture.
8.40.
8.40 am.
After that, you can save
this schedule.
You can add more lectures.
You have defined the second lecture.
My first lecture is 8 to 8.40.
Automatically, lecture 2
starts from 8.40.
When is my second lecture starting?
Can you tell us when is your second lecture starting?
9.20.
I am creating only two lectures.
I created two lectures.
I saved the schedule.
I am asking for all the schedules.
You have to add all the timings.
Lecture 3,
from 9.20.
Till when is the third lecture starting?
Till 10 o'clock.
Then, your fourth lecture will start.
Till when is your fourth lecture starting?
Till 10.40.
When is your break starting?
After 10.40,
I have a 10-minute break.
So, this is your break
in lecture 5, right?
Yes, till 10.50.
Till 10.50.
Then, your lecture 6.
6.
This is 10.50
to 11.30.
11.30.
From 11.30,
your break starts.
Till 12.5.
Is your break single?
Yes.
After lecture 6,
your break will start.
I will put the time.
What is your break?
It is your lecture 9.
If you start from 1, it will go up to lecture 9.
If you start from 0, it will go up to lecture 8.
Make that as per your own.
I am making it like this for the test.
Will it change?
Yes, it will change.
We have just created it like this.
We have added the schedule of the lecture.
It will change completely.
It will be according to your choice.
Give me a minute.
OK sir, what is next?
You can now add the timetable.
Class 5's lecture schedule that I made
using the name of class 5.
OK?
Now according to the schedule
of class 5.
Your timing is coming,
you can change now.
Whatever you feel like.
Then you have it
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
How is each subject?
You have to add the name of the subject.
There is a single subject.
Add the subject.
I have mapped two teachers for English for the subject.
I have selected them.
I will push.
I have the subject.
I will remove it.
You can also remove it from here.
I have clicked on it.
Subject English.
Name of the employee.
Push.
You have mapped the teacher.
If you feel there is someone else on Tuesday,
then the same option will remain.
You have to define the break from here.
Define the break from here.
You can also run two subjects at the same time.
There is an option for another.
If there is someone else, you can add that too.
It is proper to define the subject on Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday.
Define the subject and push from there.
There is a break on that date and time period.
If you click on it and toggle on the break,
then the break will start.
Same push and remove.
Both options remain.
In this part, how to create a timetable in a query?